et parce qu'en fait on a suivi la
méthodologie russe qui est qu'elle veut
conquérir tout le donbass mais déjà dans
un premier temps elle s'était appris à
l'april obs de lougansk est maintenant
elle s'occupe de données est ce qu'une
fois qu'elle a eue les grandes villes
qui était qu'elle devait avoir alors
craint à tort ce que c'est une évidence
parce que c'est là que et le siège en
fait une craignent un sela qui est aussi
le siège du pouvoir dont ça se sera
l'assaut final c'est là où on verra
quand ça tombera évidemment que la
dernière résistance ukrainienne est
parti et puis un bar content parce que
c'est plus logique dans la premier au
côté de l'axé effectivement sur sur
cette région là avec toujours des tirs
d'artillerie très important et on voit
une résistance rue ce qui est assez
organisée par rapport à ça et que de
toute manière il le reste des munitions
donc ils vont continuer et puis que le
moral des ukrainiens là dessus il était
maintenant assez quand même abîmé parce
que on est sur des combats qui sont
difficiles on est aussi sur le fait
qu'ils attendent des armes mais ça c'est
j'allais dire c'est le discours officiel
pour retrouver le moral dans la réalité
vous avez forcément des morts vous avez
des blessés et vous voyez bien qu'à un
moment donné vous devez reculé dans
cette zone là voyez pas le choix tu es
vous lisiez 1 c'est pas le cido nièce
que va tomber mais plutôt quand et puis
plus au nord la ville de kharkiv est
elle aussi attaquée comment est ce que
peuvent réagir ces ukrainiens alors la
ville de kharkiv c'est vrai que ça c'est
une volonté s'il ya des russes d'obtenir
effectivement à cette ville lac est
quand même une des grandes villes de
l'ukraine qui a été aussi le centre
culturel de le cred avec cette une ville
université c'est une ville qui faisait
vraiment pendant à kiev et donc les
ukrainiens n'ont pas du tout envie que
aux comptes est kharkiv tombe entre les
mains des russes et puis il y avait déjà
des guerres précédentes où ils ont
réussi justement à résister aux russes
donc c'est quand même une ville
emblématique et à ses vraies cueillies
va certainement y avoir une mobilisation
plus importante à ce niveau là et
j'espère conserver kharkiv de la même
manière qu'on espère conserver aussi
odessa côté ukrainien pour avoir cet
accès à la mer noire donc tout ça va
demander évidemment d'avoir à la fois du
moral d'avoir à la fois de l'armement et
quelques conseils stratégiques pour
savoir comment faire et on est en train
de voir effectivement qu'en plus ce qui
est compliqué pour les ukrainiens
c'est que cette guerre on en parle bien
évidemment encore mais elle commence à
rentrer dans les habitudes et on a
l'habitude à france24 d'avoir des
conflits plus élu dure plus il semble
gourou en quelque sorte